our good friend ed Gibbon wrote of
ancient Rome that the devout polytheists
though fondly attached to his national
rights admitted with implicit faith the
different religions of the earth fear
gratitude and curiosity a dream or a
gnome in the singular disorder or a
distant journey perpetually disposed him
to multiply the articles of his belief
and to enlarge the list of his
protectors polytheism is a chaotic and
historically beautiful condition it's
not so hard to imagine our forefathers
of antiquity devoid as they were of
explanations for earthquakes or
debilitating diseases stars it's not so
hard to imagine them assigning these
mysterious forces a personage a deity of
what else distinctly human shape and
character whose job it was to oversee
this or that sphere of existence this
way of thinking is called mythos in
which the world and its forces are
described by stories of holy origin when
the mythical man wants to explain the
universe he does it based on gods and
powers and if he is a more elegant
thinker in fiction and allegory the
worldview of mythos and polytheism is
necessarily disorder anarchic there need
be no unifying principle to connect
things because the universe as such is
at the caprices of these gods and
goddesses who to read the poetry about
them agree about as much as we humans do
now there was one institution that can't
exist in a world dominated exclusively
by mythos and that is the institution of
science why well because we know that
the foundational principle of science is
the principle of no contradiction in
other words a scientific theory is only
valid until a contradiction is found in
which case said theory must be revised
or scrapped nothing in polytheism
resembles this kind of logic
contradiction in mythos is totally
acceptable so where does science come
from well this is perhaps the greatest
irony of all science proceeds
historically from monotheism a belief
system held originally by the Jews that
there was one all-powerful God from
whose massive mind comes
uniform ordered universe makes sense
doesn't it for science to work it must
assume that the universe is organized by
a unifying principle an idea that
doesn't appear until the early 6th
century BC when exiled Jews in Babylon
begin the process of redacted the many
texts of the Hebrew tradition into what
became the Old Testament was fail ease a
pre-socratic Malaysian philosopher of
the same era who saw that such a
redaction the singular texts and the
singular God it describes suggested the
principle of no contradiction if God
created a universe then it had to be
ordered and uniform and so in the person
of fail ease and the subsequent Socratic
thinkers the famous transition from
mythos to logos takes place logos is a
way of explanation concentrated around
argument what Aristotle later formalizes
as logic in which an argue where can be
brought around to the other side of a
logical dispute simply by being shown
the contradiction in his argument it's
humbling to know the closed causal
historical connection between monotheism
and modern science a connection modern
scientists are loath to mention the
truth is that science is as firmly
rooted in belief as religion for it
cannot work without the assumption that
the universe is ordered and follows the
rule of no contradiction like science
says it does now as a postscript you may
be asking yourself does this mean that
religion is as valid and epistemological
system as science since they are both
based on belief well there is a very
simple answer for that no we did it in
Los Angeles the city of dream
you know I know you know what I mean
we did it it all said - that is the city
of dream